ow now what is it you were saying no
we've got to hand it to you duffer
brothers you guys really set the bar
high when it comes to sci-fi horror TV
series we've been binge watching season
after season ever since we first met 11
in the gang you guys managed to catch
the perfect actors and we seriously
wouldn't change a thing well okay maybe
we would change one thing and that's
bringing barb back to life there's no
doubt about it stranger things is one of
the best Netflix originals of all time
the series never disappoints and we're
super excited for season four we've got
fifteen little-known facts about the
cast of stranger things coming your way
keep watching to find out which cast
member has super famous parents okay
what the hell Millie Bobby Brown wanted
to quit acting being an actor can be
tough especially when you pour your
heart out in audition - only to not make
the final cut this was the case for
Milli who was being considered for the
role of x-23 in Logan but didn't land
the part Millie was ready to quit acting
altogether but luckily landing the role
of 11 kept her in the acting game Baker
Montgomery's wild audition when you
really want a role you've got to prove
it and that's just what Decker
Montgomery did Baker wore some very tiny
Underpants and danced shirtless - come
on Eileen in his audition tape and sent
it in it was a risky move but it all
paid off in the end
Sadie's height almost cost her the role
of max we couldn't imagine anyone else
but Sadie Cink playing the role of max
but at one point
Sadie almost lost the role due to her
being too tall the producers didn't want
Sadie towering over the boys luckily the
boys had a sudden growth spurt allowing
Sadie to keep the part Noah snap has a
twin it's always fun to find out that
one of your favorite actors actually has
a twin so fans were super surprised when
Noah snap revealed that he had a twin
sister named Chloe Chloe isn't a
spitting image of Noah though after all
they're fraternal twins not identical
barb was Shannon Purser's first role
before becoming the famous actress she
is today
/ sir was just a regular kid with a
dream of making it big did you know that
Shannon's first ever role was the one of
Barbra Holland on stranger things after
her character was killed off the show
Shannon's acting career took off in a
flash Charlie and Milly are from England
it isn't uncommon for actors to switch
up their accents to land a role and
that's exactly what Milly Bobby Brown
and Charlie Heaton did to be cast as 11
and Jonathan respectively you would
never guess that these two actors have
British accents stranger text group chat
have you ever wondered how the cast of
stranger things keeps in touch well they
use group chats just like the rest of us
funny enough they chose to name their
group chat stranger texts the og cast
almost got replaced stranger things is a
TV series that has evolved tremendously
over the years
originally the show was supposed to have
an entirely different cast and plot
every single season so the og cast was
meant to be replaced by the time season
two rolled around
luckily the duffer brothers chose
against this Shannon purser had to quit
her day job we previously mentioned that
playing barb was Shannon Purser's first
gig ever but did you know that Shannon
chose to keep her day job despite
landing a role on stranger things in the
end Shannon had to quit her day job
because diehard fans kept showing up to
the movie theater she worked at Gaytan
didn't have to audition in person it's
normal for actors to send audition tapes
instead of showing up in person but
usually if a casting agent is interested
the actor is asked to audition in person
as well this wasn't the case for Gaytan
Matarazzo
who was immediately cast by the duffer
brothers after they watched his tape
Stephen King is a huge milli fan
contrary to popular belief Millie Bobby
Brown had already acted in a few
productions before being cast as 11 the
renowned horror writer Stephen King
became a fan of Millie's while watching
the show intruders
he even tweeted about her terrific
acting skills before she ever made it
big in America Milly is partially deaf
Milly Bobby Brown is quickly becoming
one of the most popular teenage actors
in the world
but did you know that milli is actually
death in one ear she was born with
partial hearing and her condition
worsened over time but that hasn't
stopped her from singing and rapping the
duffer brothers convinced Winona Ryder
to play Joyce the duffer brothers were
hell-bent on getting Winona Ryder to
accept the role of Joyce Byers but as it
turns out convincing the a-lister took a
lot longer than expected but after a
four and a half hour meeting
Winona finally decided to take on the
role Milly is a goodwill ambassador for
UNICEF
she might only be 15 years old but Milly
Bobby Brown means business she became
UNICEF's youngest goodwill ambassador in
2018 and continues to help the less
fortunate on her philanthropic journey
Mya Hawks parents are super famous
here's something that just might shock
you Maya Hawk who plays Robin and
stranger things season 3 is the daughter
of some very famous actors Maya's dad is
Ethan Hawke and her mother is uma
Thurman so there you have it guys 15
little-known facts about the cast of
stranger things before you go tell us
who your top three favorite characters
are in the comment section give this
video a big thumbs up and don't forget
to subscribe to the things thanks for
watching see you soon
[Music]